[Music]
20 years ago the Nobel laureate Francis
Crick made what must have seemed at the
time a very bold claim this is what he
said you your joys and your sorrows your
memories and your ambitions your sense
of personal identity and your free will
are in fact no more than the behavior of
a vast assembly of nerve cells and their
associated molecules now when Francis
Crick said that in the astonishing
hypothesis you have to keep in mind that
at that time brain imaging wasn't it was
in its infancy that philosophers of mind
didn't care very much or didn't know
very much about what neuroscientists had
to say about how the brain worked but of
course now all of that's changed and
brain imaging has become an
indispensable tool and so we can peer
into the minds of people when they're
engaged in mental activities from
thinking about complex problems to
pondering their sense of self and
philosophers philosophers of mind
philosophers and neuroscience to become
intrigued with how the brain operates I
actually believe that we're on the
threshold of really coming to grips with
a biological understanding of
consciousness and this this question of
where consciousness comes from I think
is one of the most fundamental questions
one of the most intriguing questions in
science today one of our great mysteries
on a par with the origin of the universe
and so what I'm gonna say
right now in fact I'm just going to hand
off the microphone to my good friend
colleague and co-director Adrian Owen
who will tell you about our CFR program
on brain mind and consciousness and how
the brain gives rise to mind Adrian
thanks very much smell ah now what is
consciousness
I had a first blush that may seem like a
pretty simple question but think about
it for just a few seconds and I think
you realize it very quickly becomes
incredibly complex consciousness is
possibly the most intimate of human
mental experiences it's the one that
between us we find the most difficult to
describe to one another or to explain
let me tell you that consciousness is
the way that you are understanding what
you're hearing right now it's the way
that it provides the mechanism by which
you're going to remember the wonderful
dinner that you've had this evening it
provides the apparatus that I will allow
you to enjoy fine art and music and it
allows you to daydream about plans that
you might have for tomorrow basically
consciousness is is everything it
provides your entire view of the world
yet mysteriously it it disappears or
it's severely diminished every night
when we go to sleep and even more
worryingly it can be extinguished
completely and suddenly by something as
simple as a blow to the head so our big
question is how does this three-pound
lump of gray and white matter that you
all have sitting inside your heads give
rise to every thought feeling emotion
and plan that you have ever made and how
is it that it can go wrong in such a
multitude of different ways and the
answer to that question has huge
implications for many many fields not
only my own field neuroscience but also
education brain injury of course what
goes wrong when the brain is injured
artificial intelligence robotics
philosophy lorem policy essex psychology
even art music and creativity and
perhaps most importantly mental health
what we plan to do in our c-file program
is to bring together some of the
brightest minds on the planet to tackle
what I think are some of the biggest
questions remaining about how the brain
gives rise to consciousness let me tell
you about some of the questions that we
hope to address over the next few years
now first what is it that is so distinct
about human consciousness you're a ball
and watch nature programs in your scene
animals and it's clear that many other
species have many of the same
expressions and actions as humans but
but are those species conscious and if
so how is their consciousness different
to ours so one question I'm interested
in is basically what is it like to be an
ape right I'm sure you've all wondered
that why is it that other species do not
derive pleasure from music and art the
way that humans almost all do we know
that we can teach animals very
complicated sequences of actions animals
can perform extraordinary things they've
taught to do that or non-human species
but no species other than humans will
spontaneously tap their foot to a simple
tune why is that what have we got that
they don't have another question we're
interested in is how does consciousness
begin when I look at my one-year-old son
here scrutinizing the wheel of his his
stroller obviously he has consciousness
he's conscious but I I don't think his
consciousness is quite the same as mine
he doesn't have the same experience of
the world that I'm having right now most
of us agree I think that a fetus is not
conscious so somewhere between there
here and what's going on in my head
consciousness evolves it develops and
we're really interested in trying to
understand how that happens how does
consciousness develop and what is the
mechanism by which an infant or a young
child
starts to experience the way to us
experience the world in a way that we as
adults do supercomputers like big blue
and they can perform extraordinary feats
they can perform the very the most
complex cognitive feats perhaps better
in some cases than many humans if any of
you have tried to communicate with your
iPhone via Siri you may also think that
that phone has some kind of intelligence
right well is that consciousness is that
a kind of consciousness or is that
something else if as most of us believe
consciousness is a purely material
phenomena and then can we build a
machine that's functionally identical to
the human brain even insofar as having
some sense of consciousness or some
level of consciousness that's not a
question we're really interested in what
about so-called disorders of
consciousness now this is the field that
I spend most of my time working in can
patients who are in a vegetative state
or a coma following a serious brain
injury can they Harbor islands of
residual consciousness
despite overtly appearing to be
behaviorally non-responsive and we know
from look in my own lab that the answer
to that is yes they can and we can
detect those reduced levels of
consciousness using very sophisticated
brain imaging techniques
neuropsychiatric disorders like
schizophrenia and autism are also often
characterized by changes in
consciousness this time not in the level
of consciousness but in the contents of
consciousness think about things like
hallucinations and delusions those are
changes clearly changes in the cont the
conscious perceptions of the patient and
recent recent advances in cognitive
neurosciences are starting to shed light
on how this happens what changes in the
brain are necessary to induce these
unfortunate alterations in the contents
of consciousness and by learning more
about the biological underpinnings of
higher cognitive functions of these
complex cognitive processes we're going
to be able to identify precursors of
other diseases neurodegenerative
diseases alike like alzheimers disease
and Parkinson's disease what about drugs
you'll know about drugs prescription
drugs and recreational drugs are very
capable and often do induce so-called
alterations in consciousness changes in
consciousness think sedation is an
obvious example but also increases in
creativity increases in arousal
disinhibition many drugs produce many
changes that many behavioral changes
that suggest changes again in the
contents or the level of consciousness
it's interesting I think that in
different cultures these changes are
sometimes thought of as being
constructive and sometimes destructive
it depends where you are at what you
think about these these changes
particularly for example in changes in
creativity in response to recreational
drugs recent brain imaging studies are
starting to shed light on how it is that
drugs induce changes in the brain
typically changes in the
neurotransmitters of the brain and how
these go these changes go on to induce
the behavioural changes that we know
characteristic of drug use and finally
how is it that all of us are sitting in
this room are able to enjoy looking at a
piece of fine art or sway together to
the sound classic symphony or indeed cry
at the the same point of our favorite
movie is that some kind of collective
consciousness is there something that
binds us together and allows us to share
these inner mental experiences share
with each other and describe what
they're like we're interested in the
concept of collective consciousness now
these are all really big questions and
to address those really big questions
we're going to get some really big
people and those really big people are
gonna come from many different fields so
we're assembling a multidisciplinary
team and this is a truly
multidisciplinary program it will take
people from cognitive neuroscience my
own field but also from medicine we'll
use what will involve neurologists and
psychiatrists anesthesiologists
obviously are involved in changes in the
level of consciousness but also we want
we want to involve ethicists and
philosophers and psychologists
anthropologists people who have other
views of consciousness and this is I
think really where this program could
only be funded by CFR because this group
of people are not people that usually
meet each other let alone talk to one
another we're going to put them all in a
room and we're going to get them all
working on the same problem which is how
does the brain give rise to
consciousness
so in summary we're going to take the
most recent advances cutting-edge ideas
in areas like cognitive neuroscience
philosophical thinking computational
modeling and we're going to push all
this towards the solution of a single
problem which is how does consciousness
arise from the neural machinery of the
brain in doing so I do think this is a
new frontier for C far I think we're
moving to a point where we will be able
to answer the question of what is the
relationship between brain and mind and
essentially I think what that addresses
is what is it that really makes us human
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]